[Music]
the division around weekend began with
Andrew Luck taking on Patrick mahomes in
Kansas City and even though Patrick
Holmes did not have a touchdown pass he
had a touchdown round he put the ball on
the pylon didn't lose possession of it
and have it become a touchback and
mahomes ultimately getting the win and
Chris you noticed something we were on
the field before the game about the
Holmes versus luck just throwing the
ball in those weather conditions I think
you noticed where things were heading
well yeah it certainly jumped out to me
it was a concern because I you know you
and I were sitting out there in that
blizzard a pregame it was snowy it was
windy okay whatever it was cold as hell
I know that all right and it was all
agree with yes and it was windy and it
was some pretty big snowflakes coming
down but yes when I said when I we had
moments of not being on TV and I got to
turn around and watch them warm up I did
certainly think luck had some more
errant passes than Patrick mahomes who
on the other side of the field was just
throwing lasers all over the field and I
thought oh he is unaffected by these
conditions and it looks like this
passing game is not gonna be affected
today and they're gonna be able to make
a big plays and that's what he did he
came out firing
yeah Tony Dungy made the point that in
the snow the passing game actually
benefits because the pass rush has a
harder time getting to you and you know
the wind is what would get you as a
quarterback but it wasn't windy now you
could see the flags at the top of the
stadium they were tight I mean it was
windy up there but down in the bowl the
the little the little of fluorescent
flags on the on the goalposts they
weren't moving all that much right kind
of it was shifting and turning but not
enough to affect not enough to affect a
guy like mahomes no can slice a football
through anything so you saw that one
coming in and because I was at when I
saw that the Colts players seemed kind
of loose and confident maybe I'm wrong
about this one but I stuck with the
Chiefs you stuck with the Chiefs
and the Chiefs ended up prevailing yeah
definitely a great win for the Chiefs
and I think the encouraging thing too
for Chiefs fans or anybody watching that
you know hey Andy Reed showed that he's
willing to run the football a little bit
more than we all expected and that's
really good but hey there was a lot of
good quarterback play I mean will you
talk about what Brady did yesterday
right
I mean that was surgical the game plan
itself the run game all the short passes
then the play-action passes off it just
amazing there and then drew brees found
his rhythm once they finally got going
against Nick Foles Sean Payton that
offense Brees started to hit Michael
Thomas on in cuts and throws down the
field we saw some good quarterback play
this weekend and we're gonna see some
awesome one coming this way coming this
weekend with two legends against the two
young guys coming up the ranks there's
been that sense that Brady's had a knee
injury that they've kept under wraps and
that now it's healed look at how much
better he's playing he struggled through
a few weeks late in the season he looks
pretty good now he looks as good as ever
and we're gonna see I think some of the
best of Tom Brady coming up this week
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports